good morning
millennials welcome back to the morning
toast happy monday
it's so gross in here today like
negative toxic vibes oozing out of my
pores
and so toxic and i'm about to bring that
negativity straight to your ears
it's gross and humid in here today and
it's just like the monday
energy is just seeping into everything
i'm just like
i'm in a place in my life to be honest
where i really
can't handle emotionally the stress that
is monday like i'm in such a fragile
mental state constantly
and to wake up on a monday like with an
alarm it's actually really bad for my
mental health like i feel like i need to
take all future mondays off
just to preserve my own saturday
normalize summer mondays
just normalize summer monday through
fridays i think that's for the best
i agree well how was your weekend it was
delightful i mean i have
the biggest bruise on my hip because
yesterday we went tubing with i
was at brian's we went tubing and i just
like got a little too comfortable on the
tube and you really need to look out
when
in the river like the delaware river
does not play around
and i just got like a little too
comfortable like having a drink and
there was a rock coming and i didn't
know and it literally
went up my ass like boom and it all
happened so fast and like i was
it was blinding you know when you get
like a pain and you can't see
like like when you bang your knee at
dale first goes
i do know that's jackie's favorite story
it's so funny it was exactly that but
bigger and like wealthier and it all
happened so fast because
10 hours later when i was sleeping all
night last night it was like throbbing
i'm so sorry it's been a journey for me
but you know that's what you get when
you're a river rat
that is what you are so i'm glad you had
a nice fun weekend it seemed like dude
had a wonderful weekend he seems pooped
it was a great weekend for me i didn't
want to be home alone like again i was
home alone all week
ben has finally returned and it's such a
delight to like not walk into my home
and think there's a murderer
it's just been it's just been also also
a murderer but
different different vibes that's nice i
had the most like boring loki weekend i
did something that i haven't done in
like literal years which is that like i
watch
tv all weekend i watch so much stuff
i'll tell you guys about everything
me too [ __ ] weird stuff too i because
usually i've just been like reading so
much or like
getting up and adam and i just like
didn't do that because it was so hot
this weekend i was just like i'm gonna
stay in the ac
brew was like not really feeling
anything either so
we watched a show upstairs downstairs
which is like kind of like downton abbey
and it's from
it's kind of like dynasty where it's
like an old show that they brought back
got it
and they brought it back and they
canceled it pretty quickly so it was
only like 10 episodes total but like
claire foy is in it and she's
awful oh my god if i had seen the show
before the crown i would have been like
not you thought she was a terrible
actress no no no not the acting
her character is like this horrible nazi
woman and i it was horrible to watch and
like really disturbing
but the show was really good so highly
recommend then i watched darkest hour
that movie about winston churchill
um yeah with that gary oldman yes oh
yeah
yeah it's just one of those movies that
like focuses obviously on like a major
figure
and like 10 days of their life oh my god
not the dad i hate that [ __ ]
actually jackie probably the 10
worst most stressful days of his life oh
my god you know what it was it was his
darkest
hour oh i guess that tracks
i hate when [ __ ] movies do that it's
like a six hour you know time period
like
jackie that terror of almost yeah i
think about like
or on my weekend with marilyn atrocious
a church just like give us the scope
we want the scope yeah we scoop on the
scope we really really do
so i would like oh my god but i was
dying with all the churchill stuff and
like
he said he talked about it so much
because he started
doing it like this at first and then his
um employee told him that like that
means like up your ass
but she was like in britain so she was
like if you flip it
it means peace victory got it or vagina
he said it means victory so that was
really a fun fact it was
it was a fine movie you guys don't need
to watch it you're like you're such a
grandma like with the things that you
choose to watch like
all about like old britain well here's
why i watched that after
upstairs downstairs because the upstairs
downstairs ended like at the
dawn of world war ii in britain like war
breaks out
show ends spoiler alert and then i was
like oh okay what happens next so i was
like i want to watch something
chronological
churchill even though there was like a
few years in between churchy vibes
it was churchy vibe well i watched
something totally different but i swear
to god it was the best show i've seen
okay actually i watched so much tv i had
like an active and relaxing weekend
first i watched all of hacks on hbo max
and i swear to god it's the best show
i've heard such good things oh my god
it's so good first of all the writing
is hysterical like it's just so well
done
and i don't even know who the actress is
who plays this comedian who i have to
imagine
is very based
on joan rivers like she's this iconic
legend comedian opened the door for so
many women
and she does qvc like it was so joan
rivers even though like she didn't live
in vegas and she never had a vegas
residency
whatever it is so good the writing is so
funny it is hysterical i loved it i
would recommend it
took me like one afternoon to watch it's
10 episodes and they're each 30 minutes
then i watched this documentary called
cher
and the loneliest elephant and i swear
to god
it was like funny but like not cause
like i didn't really understand cher's
involvement in the documentary like of
course she brought a global audience to
this issue but
she didn't really do much i thought she
like funded this you know
they basically freed this elephant that
was in these horrible conditions for
like 20 years
in the zoo in pakistan and the pakistani
um government like ruled
that whatever they got but the only
place for the elephant to go was a
sanctuary in cambodia which is a seven
hour flight and then a four-hour drive
and there's the elephant on a plane so
this is an elephant with like crazy ptsd
he has anger issues he's killed two of
his handlers because like
uh he's in captivity and so they had to
like
work for months to get him in a good
place mentally so that they can
tranquilize him but
tranquilize him enough that he still has
to stand on a cargo plane
and whatever he made it successfully and
like cher was you know really following
the whole thing on twitter and then she
went to
um pakistan like the day that they
brought him to cambodia and like
it was just funny because like the
documentary had nothing to do with chair
like
yes she tweeted about it but like that
doctor did everything and that doctor at
the end of the documentary had to say
goodbye to come on
after they had been like bonding for
three months and he said like the first
rule of veterinary like you cannot get
attached to the animals but of course he
got attached to him on it like this
little man was like crying
saying goodbye to the elephant and like
i couldn't stop crying it was the
saddest documentary of course it had a
happy ending
and the whole documentary had to share
soundtrack which is why cher's presence
was worth it because the second he lands
in cambodia they start playing
this is a song for the lonely
and it was so emotional and it was
stunning wow
then i watched some olympics
qualification matches which i promised i
would do
and boy did they deliver first of all
caleb dressle i want to say that's his
name
he's a swimmer he won all of it
ryan lochte didn't even qualify i know
he might be going back to the e-network
honestly it was so like like awkward to
watch
because like they kept interviewing him
and they were actually like he was dying
he was like
this is your last day on earth how do
you feel and he was like i feel good i
just wanna like mentor these young kids
yadda yadda
it was so awkward i honestly felt really
bad for him but this guy caleb oh my god
first of all he's like the next michael
phelps is he the one to watch
you never saw anyone so hot in your
whole life like it was like the stadium
was quaking
from his sexiness like obsessed of
course he's married then
i watched the javelin throw no what's
that like 16-pound ball
shot put sure um javelin i think you're
right no javelin i feel like is this
trunchable does she do it with a chain
yeah for sure
no so there's no chain in this one i
watched
i don't whatever cheat shot put chap it
was like 15 jason mamoas throwing
big balls and this one guy set a world
record look at the qualifications like
he is the star of our
javelin whatever it's called team um
javelin team
um going to the olympics so i just feel
like i know a lot
about what's going on i'm briefed and
the official u.s song of the olympics is
remember this by the jonas brothers and
it was
i honestly almost cried like it was so
empowering wow that's beautiful
it was good it's a good song have you
heard it no but i'm looking forward to
it because the olympics music
is the best music like i actually have a
whole place give me a pickup truck
i have a whole playlist on my spotify of
the olympic songs that have been through
the years the avicii one
and they're all so good there and like
even when taylor swift rascal flats when
they like
switch their songs up like she did
change olympics version rascal flatts
did um
wait what yeah taylor swift has a cover
of change
that's for the olympics oh i'm sorry yes
okay i thought you were talking about
change
the rascal flat song but change her song
change herself okay okay and they
have one of their songs unstoppable
that's an olympics version
it's a beautiful industry whoever's in
charge of the olympic soundtrack
does an amazing deserves a race year
after year year after well
every four years yeah but they're
working so hard in every two years no no
it's
oh 100 yeah and honestly for the next
two years it's
year after year yeah also um
but oh speaking of veterinarians i
watched i started the new season of
wyoming kale have you watched it yes
what part did you get up to i actually
had a spoiler alert i don't want anyone
i stopped watching because
i was upset with hama okay so i only
watched the first two episodes like she
found out the big bad secret
okay and then that neighbor okay
that's the last thing i watched you and
when they decided to be morons
to be morons and spoiler alert bury her
in the yard as opposed to calling the
police they could have came up with any
reason as to why she fell no and the
reason they could be wrong
no they could have been like no but what
was she climbing up to find out they
could have said like infidelity maybe
she's a busy body it's not on them to
figure out
no literally maybe she was trying to
steal maybe it's not their
they don't know why there was a crazy
woman climbing up the ladder i turned it
off because
i can't relate to amma anymore i know
and like when alma was just trying to
like get invited to the garden party
like i honestly could have cried for her
she was so pathetic no so pathetic like
literally will live with a murderer to
go to a garden party
it's can't relate it's loser on loser
crime no it was way too losery like ammo
was supposed to be like that loser that
like you're rooting for you're
she like you are her biggest fan no but
i'm i'm really not
so i i i stopped watching okay i agree
um
i probably will finish it because i'm a
loser with nothing to do maybe when all
the episodes come out but like
i just you have to make your feelings
known when something upsets you
mark cherry hear ye hear you like alma
is not the protagonist you thought she
was
she might be the antagonist would you
say marge terry mark cherry
mark who's marsh terry like you said
mark cherry's the creator of the show i
it sounded like you said
marge terry you know i didn't say march
terry so much so that i had no idea what
you meant and they had to clarify
that's fine i mean that's a you problem
because i said it very normally
roll it back roll it back um before we
dive in i have to share a very funny
experience i had this morning on my way
here
okay i was walking which was a crazy
thing to do because it's so [ __ ] hot
i spent like two hours on my hair
um and i ran into this like fabulous
young woman who was a toaster and she
was like oh i'm waiting for today's
episode i was like love you like it was
like a great
moment for women and then she was like
the show was just so good like you guys
are so articulate
and i was like this is a prank like no
one's ever said that
ever like we're hilarious like we're
crazy articulate
and at first she was like making fun of
us but she was like dead [ __ ] serious
um no i think that some people feel that
way about us clown
i don't i think you've been so bogged
down by the negativity
oh my god and the people who like say
claudia's this claudia is that what are
they saying
[Laughter]
you actually don't know how to receive a
compliment no no that's like okay tell
me like my shirt
i like and i did tell you this earlier
you say it i said i like your shirt
thanks it's literally a taller i pulled
it out of a dumpster like i cannot take
a compliment if you compliment something
i'm wearing i'm like oh thanks i stole
it like
i have to say something like really
negative like really it was so cheap
it's a piece of [ __ ]
no but i feel like it's not something
that you have to say something negative
you just like can't accept the praise so
like you need to make it
somehow like relatable no i'm like so
humble
and that's what makes you not like other
girls well at the end of the day
i'm not like other girls and i think
it's so important that nobody forgets
that
yeah i think that they might forget it
if you didn't remind them all the time
and that's why that's why i come here
and do what i do and articulate what you
articulate in a very articulate way so
to that toaster i hope you enjoyed this
episode
and i'll try and be extra articulate for
you today that's really a nice sweet
thing to say
we have a great show it's monday which
makes it torture but
so much to discuss the kardashians final
episode of our generation
on e was on last night and i watched it
in the back of a car i had such a
journey last night i could
you know we're always talking about car
services my car service left me high and
dry yesterday at brian's like literally
they never came so i had to call a local
taxi company it was like such a journey
i thought i was gonna get objected but i
made it home and in my time warner cable
app
really saved me because i watched the
entire kardashians on the way home so i
got i got home and like went straight to
sleep so i'd have the most premium
viewing experience but i still watched
it
well you know what it could have been a
podcast because it was just premium
conversations being had
but like you you do want to see the
beauty of the women and you know what i
really i don't want to get too much into
it because we'll do it in the tv recap
i thought that last night's episode was
like the kendall jenner episode
like she was making points left right
center
and she was looking so gorgeous i don't
think she said one word in the first
part
so i didn't notice like how stunning her
face was looking but that was a perfect
face
yeah no she she that's like she's the
biggest supermodel in the world because
she has a perfect face
you know it was nice to see her like
feeling some sort of way and taking up
for
speak up for herself that bother her and
so
and like to defend her sisters and stuff
because i feel like usually she sort of
hangs back so that was nice to see
for me it was the chloe episode and i
felt like people thought part one was
became episode it was just the way in
which andy was directing his questions
yeah i thought everybody had an amazing
we'll talk about it
but just like small takeaway
like the best tv ever if you haven't
watched
it treat yourself honestly andy cohen
deserves an emmy like just for that
special i thought he did
an incredible job a pulitzer pulitzer
the pulitzer pulitz is a pillow to the
nobel peace prize is that the same thing
not the same thing but he also deserves
a nobel peace prize
do you get money for a pulitzer because
i know you get a million dollars for a
nobel peace prize
gotta win one i don't know if you get
money for a pulitzer
i'm just thinking about it okay now
without further ado where are you
sleeping right here
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
bruce the greatest electric toothbrush
on the market says who
me that's who and i'm articulate so you
should listen to me
bruce is our favorite toothbrush it's
the official toothbrush of the toasters
everyone's got one and if you don't have
one like
you really want to be left out like that
you should go get one the brush offers
six unique modes to customize your
brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
a compact travel case
they offer a subscription program so you
never forget to change your brush head
again
bruce will ship you new replacement
heads every six months so you're never
stuck
using a worn down brush head that gives
you bad breath and then no one wants to
kiss you
it comes with a very sleek design i have
two now actually i have like a
millennial blush pink and this like
stunning hunter green
um just perfect for my moods you know
whether i'm feeling you know green or
pink
which are the official toaster colors so
it's just very appropriate
the electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design that comes
in trend driven seasonal colors and it
looks great on your bathroom counter
they also just launch brand new colors
so check it out get 15 off your brush
toothbrush kit and refill plan when you
use the promo code toast at bruce.com
that's 15 off using code toast
at bruush.com bruce
get your teeth clean get your teeth
clean
use it twice a day every day probably
the sponsor we use most just you know
because we're always brushing those
teeth yeah i mean there was a period in
my life like i'm
i'm constantly being transparent here in
the morning i think we know this about
you
do you know what i'm about to say no you
didn't brush your teeth twice a day no
i like honestly there was like a good
five years i was like just doing in the
morning
yeah but then you got the bruce and it
got you excited to brush your teeth
and like when it's all dentists there
was like no like emergencies so like i
thought it was fine you know and also
the bruce i cleared up all those years
of
dust and plaque yeah okay first story
this one goes out to claudia
taylor swift announces a release date
for her version of her
album red fans have speculated for
months that she would surprise 50s with
a june 18th midnight drop of 1989
however she announced on friday that
2012's red will be the next re-recorded
album on her agenda
says page six but i know that claudia
has a different perspective i do
but i have since debunked my own theory
okay well she's
red will be available on november 19th
and this is really exciting news why did
you debunk your theory
okay let me just start out by saying i'm
not upset
well i'm not not upset i'm not upset
about the choice i did think 1989 was
coming any day now like i've been
you know clowning around every thursday
for the last like four weeks like
thinking that it was coming on friday
like that was just me
and i was pretty much convinced that
1989 was the next selection 1989 is my
favorite album
ever written um but i'm not mad that red
is the next choice
i'm mad that it's coming in november
like what the [ __ ] are we supposed to do
until then like that's so long
and i don't understand announcing a june
on june
i know she announced on june 18th not
because it's the annual anniversary of
my bat mitzvah
which it is but because it's scooter
bronze birthday says june 18th
yeah shows me and lives oh then mine was
june 16th they always get confused [ __ ]
i miss anniversary
it's okay she's there's always next year
oh my god it was like so skinny and my
mom it's fun i had sidebangs and i wore
like the sickest dress that was so
gorgeous um
i'm i'm pl i love red i love for a while
red was my favorite album like there's
so much to unpack on red state of grace
like
you're my achilles heel like so good
i just can't believe we have to wait
until november taylor's been on this
thing where like she's just been
dropping albums like when she feels like
it on a thursday and it comes out on
friday like we haven't had to wait
since love her that was three albums ago
we did have to wait for fearless
she told us like months before i
remember feeling like april was so far
away
yeah but now i just feel like okay so we
have 1989 to record we have a red to
record we have debut to record we have
uh lover no we have a speak now to
record
is there one more whatever so we have
five more to come
and six months in between that's 30
months
so it's like we're gonna like i just
feel like the re-recordings is amazing
but i want taylor to move on with her
life and like i'm sure she has new music
she wants to drop
i kind of wish she just like dumped it
all out at once you know yeah do you
think she'll re-record debut and speak
now
i don't think so 100 speak now
but wouldn't she have done that next no
i don't think she's going in any
particular order like
i think that honestly red is a very
autumnal album
so on the on the schedule like if you're
gonna listen to an album like as the
leaves change
it's gonna be red yeah but then november
is
autumn still but it's late autumn like
she should be giving us
red in september or october i agree with
you i feel like
there's something in between there has
to be so i really thought that like she
was announcing red in november
and then like literally speak now in
october like we're gonna work our way
back in the announcements
but she literally i didn't realize she
verbatim wrote the next album i'm
releasing
and she's very intentional with her
wording so like this is it like i
thought the cover art were stunning
i loved that message like i have always
felt like
red was this transformative album like
really putting heartbreak into words and
i felt like taylor spoke very eloquently
in her instagrams post about it like
it was all great i have nothing to
complain about it's just like a long
time yeah
i agree and you know me like i can't
wait i can't get through a two-hour
movie
i don't think she's gonna re-record her
debut album and speak now
i don't think she's going to re-record
every single album i think she'll do
like a greatest hits from those
well that's crazy i feel like she's
going to record every single one
maybe over time but not before she puts
out her next album
it's just like if you hear that yeah of
course but it'll be confusing like 1989
red
wood veil like a new album like that's
just like confusing to me like i would
just wish we could get all i know she
has them all recorded ready like i
we know wilde's dreams is already
recorded because they're using it in a
trailer for some new
cartoon movie starring jake gyllenhaal
like the horse movie sure
the horse i see a train it's the train
horse movie like
we know i know she already has like half
of these already done so like just
banging out
and then you get to move on with your
life i feel like this has just been like
a toxic time for her i agree she can
leave it in the past the sooner it gets
out there i'm sure there's a method to
the madness it just doesn't seem to make
sense
and anyone who's going on and like
listening to old taylor swift music is
generating revenue dollars for scooter
run so wouldn't you just want to get it
out as soon as possible because
now when i listen to fearless i'm
listening to taylor's version they're
literally the same and of course i'd
rather listen
for taylor to the taylor's version so if
they were just all out like she could
just
cut her losses yeah financially yeah i
agree with that
she was just a little annoying but again
not complaining because like
she's giving us more than most fans ever
get no no and taylor swift fans like we
used to get
nothing like we're getting so much i'm
really trying not to complain i'm just
like obsessed
and like the 10 minute version of all
too well that we're getting
she said in her caption there's a song
she's releasing 30 songs
um i don't know i think it was like 17
something there was a lot on the album
not 30.
so we're getting a new version of all 2l
which is the original that was 10
minutes that the record label made her
cut like that's gonna be
like like drowning in a bathtub like
throw a toaster in like i'm done you
know
um there's just a lot good that and i'm
excited i just i truly cannot wait like
what am i supposed to do until then
listen to the other stuff you know i
totally forgot about
folklore and evermore for like the last
six months what i'm saying
i forgot about them but i need to get
back into them because those were such
good times
remember love her like don't know her
like that was literally like you
literally have completely forgotten
about
reputation didn't even mention it in
recapping all of her albums
okay because i have something absolutely
crazy to say and i
like the swifties are gonna come from my
throat like they're gonna kill me
i do not like reputation like i i really
like i will skip it every time
and i'm gonna say i think reputation was
ahead of its time no and so many people
like think it's her best album like i
respect other people's opinions when it
comes to taylor swift
i just didn't do it for me it was like
very electric
uh i think that there are certain songs
king of my heart is stunning like there
are certain songs that do it for me
so good but i didn't appreciate it when
we had it i didn't understand it but in
hindsight like it is so good
i liked it when i had it and i listened
to it like a lot
because i'm stan but like i'm sorry i've
kind of been like afraid to admit that i
i don't like it you have to speak your
truth
yeah and like i really there's for me
1989 is a no skips album like i will not
skip one song
some of them have been ruined just by
society playing them over and over well
like blank space
yeah but also why not get off oh
sorry that's a skip um also why 1989 is
so brilliant is because i think like the
best songs on 1989 were the ones that
were like released on a cd at target
that like nobody ever heard new
romantics
wonderland like so good yeah
so that's my spell for the day so
november 19th we'll see you then red i'm
really excited up until now it has been
my favorite taylor album so let's see if
it stands to test me too like for a
while it was number one for me
yeah i mean we are gonna get a new
version of
treacherous and for that like we are so
excited
yeah because taylor swift said it first
don't take risks on treacherous roads
and we and we haven't ever since oh and
don't swim in the sea
are you ready for our next story sure a
little update for news from a while ago
but chris harrison got
nine million dollar payout from abc amid
his bachelor exit
so there was a lot of speculation he
demanded 25 million
some people were saying 50 because they
said mid 8 figure range
right we settled on about 15 million but
it turns out it was actually
9 million a combination of exit
settlement and remaining contractual
fees
and honestly like after taxes like
that's not that much
no he can't retire no we were thinking
like whatever the franchise is a sinking
ship he got 50 million dollars he'll go
on a beach smoke cigars for the rest of
his life
homeboys need to get a job like this is
not enough
i wonder what he's gonna do next i don't
know
because you could try sears
you know like he needs a job but he's
also unemployable like he's
a disgraced king yeah but you know
i'm i mean it depends what he's made of
like do you want to
rebuild yourself do you want to start a
podcast tnn is always hiring
always if you've been cancelled come
here do you want to write another book
yeah well the thing is also like have
you been smart with your money you've
been making millions
every year like have you been saving
have you been investing have you you
know started any businesses like
because you know the entertainment
industry isn't forever like for men you
have a longer
like life time span but
old is old so i hope he's been investing
wisely
maybe using robin hood i don't know
coinbase i don't know
i hope so too i hear salona is huge
but also the way we see the bachelor
going
who knows if he'd even make 9 million
more dollars in the next few years with
them
that's true as well he just like needs
to take some
like he's a kind of like having a
chrissy teigen moment like
take a break maybe just chill i mean
he's on a break he's been on a break
but he's got to work not if he invested
wisely
who knows but i hope his portfolio is
robust you know these are uncertain
times economically
they are very uncertain and maybe
investing isn't the way to go
oh you know i haven't checked my doge in
a while live on air oh you know
i've been like not hearing anything just
a headline sorry that i read are not
good for crypto
crypto is tanking apparently [ __ ] i'm
such a [ __ ]
why i got it at four cents i remember
there was so much hoopla
and it was up to 70 cents during elon
musk's and then everyone sold because
they're normal
and now it's down to 22. and i'm a [ __ ]
well hold strong don't you to the moon
that's like so sad
even if doge misses it'll hand among the
stars i
like i guess i'm so upset poor dogs
i can't check that app anymore it's like
it once brought me so much joy at least
you got in at four dollars like
four cents oh my god at least you gotta
have four cents
yeah and there's just like no movement
around doge anymore like there was a
a true campaign and now like people have
left me in the dust because they all
made money but do you believe in
the power of doge like no i don't not
anymore but you know what i think i
think
other girls still doge and i'm not like
other girls yes
okay i'll keep it it's so unique of you
i mean i'm nothing if not like other
girls so yeah
so stick with your doge and just like me
and my you know stocks
not like other girls i'm like i'm one of
the very few females on wall street
we actually have a story about wall
street um next story
is about the guy who says like you
[ __ ] have to come back to the office
it's so funny okay okay you know what we
could get right into it
is it the finance news that's brought to
you by better help yes
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours better help is not a crisis line
and it is not self-help it is
professional counseling done securely
online
there is a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available to you in many areas
better help services are available for
clients worldwide where you can log into
your account anytime and send a message
to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room again as you
do with traditional therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
better help is more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
because betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today
so many people have been using better
health that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
so today's episode is sponsored by
betterhelp and morningtoastlisteners can
get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
toast that's better h-e-l-p dot com
slash toast to get 10 off their first
month it's never too late to start
taking care of yourself
no it never is okay next story about the
guy who's telling everyone to get the
[ __ ] back to work
wall street is in a rush to get workers
back to the office
morgan stanley ceo james gorman warned
this week he'll be very disappointed
if workers aren't backed by labor day
and if they're not
quote then we'll have to have a
different kind of conversation
okay goldman sachs asked its employees
to be back at the office by this week
and walsh and the wall street bank even
ordered staffs to divulge whether
they've been vaccinated
even more than other industries wall
street is clearly in a rush to turn the
page on this extended era of virtual
work
executives employees and those who
follow the industry point to a range of
factors for this
first there are the cultural concerns
zoom calls and slack messages are no
substitute for in-person bonding and
training
others worry about the cyber security
and risk management vulnerabilities
inherent in businesses the colonial
pipeline
inherent in businesses that conduct
billions of dollars of transactions
every day yeah and like we're supposed
to trust trust like jeff's
you know spectrum network to like hold
all these facts when spectrum had a
[ __ ] outage last week 100
because they were trying to get to
jeff's facts 100 percent at its core
banking is a face-to-face business and
now they're trying to get people
back in the office the ceo of james
gorman of morgan stanley said
if you can go to a restaurant in new
york city you can come to the office
he's not lying and honestly like he's
just spitting facts
and i know it's like what people don't
want to hear because i think for the
most part some people want to get back
to the office want to get back to like
you know wearing real clothes and
speaking to people
and looking people in the eyes but i
think a lot of people are like loving
the flexibility of working from home but
you know what like
this isn't camp like they're paying you
to do a job
like get the [ __ ] back to work now i see
that comfortably you know as my own
business owner so like i would be
annoyed if i like worked in finance and
i was like loving
living life for the last year yeah i'm
just living life
but like why would any brand why would
any company pay rent on an office space
over if everyone's choosing to work from
home
no and now they're just like getting
down to the business of it which is just
like
get back to work yeah like this isn't
the [ __ ] not meant to be permanent and
they're like
if you were working remotely if you
moved get back oh well that's the thing
like so many people thought that this
was going to go on forever or or that
like office culture would never be the
same again
so people moved to florida but he made a
great point he's like you're making a
new york salary because you live in new
york so like
if you're you know operating in
idaho for a lower cost of living but
making a new york salary that's actually
not how it works
yeah no it's not how it works so it's
very interesting and i do think wall
street especially in new york sets the
tone for business around here
like when the finance bros are out at
the gem saloon like all is right in the
world and until that happens like
we're not gonna recover no i completely
agree um
i'm i'm here for this honestly like this
is what the city needs
think of all the businesses that rely on
i mean we talk about
all the time chopped just salad
the bodega the coffee shop there are so
many different
so many different places i think this is
necessary and i'm glad that we're going
to cut the [ __ ] now like
yeah yeah and you know what like not to
for nothing like we've been coming into
the office since march like
what are you doing we've no we've been
coming into office for a year now and
also like we did the zoom thing and like
i
could never like talk about lack of
productivity
talk about public i mean mental health
disaster
disaster i think that whenever i think
of my life like isn't going how i want
it to go
i think back on the times when we had to
do episodes via zoom and i always think
like
it could be worse 100 like to roll over
out of your bed and then get to work
like
you need the delineation i mean i feel
like that part of it i did enjoy i'm not
gonna lie like
to wait i have to wake up to do my hair
like i could just be sleeping and then
rolling over
that part i didn't like but like the
first of all the quality of our episodes
like talk about trash like
we tried so hard like you didn't get to
see my beautiful face every day and like
you felt the repercussions well so that
was the other thing it was like i was
kind of
taking that toll like not being able to
be graced with your presence and like
kind of that light that you have with
from within
and that was really hard for me wow
claudia that's beautiful
yeah no one so think of all your
co-workers who have that light from
within that
that's being extinguished working from
home yeah
and then like oh sometimes i just think
about remember like we used to have
those zoom game nights like that was
pathetic
you know what they actually were kind of
fun like i mean they were bright spots
in a very dark time but like now when i
look back ours were like
more fun than other people's 100 yeah no
i actually look back fondly on those
but we just like got so drunk on zoom
like that was crazy
that's when i discovered white claws and
like i literally threw up after like a
saturday night zoom session like
that's like that's illusory as well like
100 i was like
on my way to bed and i'm like i think
i'm gonna throw up and i spent like the
whole night on the toilet
yeah like zoom got so crazy yeah and
it's like wow she's desperate for a good
time
yeah no but if we can be doing all these
other things like sitting in a
restaurant and then you can sitting
around going to concerts
and there were so many concerts this
weekend and i'm sure that there are
people who you know have like a nice
setup going on at home but i think
generally speaking
working from home in productivity don't
go hand in hand no but it's good to know
that like
you can really fully do your job from
home if need be if need be and like we
said
you know i think that hopefully offices
become more flexible with remote days
like
you have your paid time off and then you
also have like work from wherever days
hopefully
and also the kids need to go back to
school because you need to have child
care for your children if you're going
to be going back to work
no the kids you guys i've been thinking
about them a lot
they're so they're gonna they're not
gonna be normal like
they're just and like i'm worried about
so many different kids right now
i'm worried about the kids who's like
development is so you know
dependent on being social like those
kids are gonna be freaks
i'm worried about the kids in medical
school who have been like learning how
to be doctors on youtube for the last
year
i'm worried about the kids in law school
who like literally like took the bar
online and like cheated the whole time
like
i'm worried about like in for the next
like five or ten years whenever i need a
doctor
i'm just gonna make sure they were not
in medical school during 2020 so that's
20 21. because i don't trust it
yeah i'm worried about the campers
really and the cameras i'm saying like
are pretty much like
age six to twelve you know
where like they're going to school and
like it's it's not
it's not a few days a week like those
are really really like
fundamental years yeah and i always and
then you're like in the bunk
in a mask it's so stupid and i keep
thinking like what was the ideal age to
go through this
because like i'm annoyed like i became i
started the pandemic 25 and like
i'm turning 27 next year like i mean
next month like kill me
so like that's not great but like i
don't know i'm
margo was 23. like i think that was
worse for margo like i just can't decide
what a good age was
honestly i think like those people who
were pregnant or got pregnant during
coped like
made the best use of their time yeah i
agree with that in the beginning of the
pandemic i remember talking about this
with my friends when we thought it was
like two weeks flat on the curve lol
um i i thought that we were actually the
worst
age because it's like if you were a
parent or you were a young kid you had
all this time to spend with like your
family and
that you would never have had before it
was like this unique opportunity like
parents getting to bond with their
children and like spending all this time
together it's really nice
but now i'm like i actually think we're
the ones who suffered the least
because we're like developed people yeah
you know we just had to like
pause yeah for a year no but i
definitely feel like angry
yeah oh for sure no but i i i go back
and forth me too
but definitely worried about the campers
the kids
think of the children really are you
ready for our next story sure
speaking of the children kevin hart
delves into his infidelity scandal with
will smith on red table talk
oh my god constantly red table talk just
like pushing boundaries
setting trends having important
conversations he talks about how
he had to talk to his kids about his
cheating scandal that's
weird that's rough he said i stepped in
some [ __ ] yeah you're never prepared for
that side of it having a little girl in
my life it's tough you don't realize the
impact that your mistakes can truly have
when the kids get involved it's a
different feeling it's a different
emotion
through my public debacles it's been
very hard to bother me but when your
child shows disappointment shows emotion
shows i don't understand why
and you gotta have those conversation
the head drops for the first time
yeah that's kind of like what happened
on the kardashians like i'm seeing the
same thing how's scott
like maybe scott's struggle with
addiction he never would have had to
have shared with his kids
like being a public figure like kevin
hart like all that information is out
there so you want to get ahead of it
when
when it comes to talking to your kids
yeah so that's really difficult to
navigate actually
but don't cheat on your wife and then
you won't have those problems yeah but
that is a
problem that just mostly celebrities
would have i guess i don't know if
i know i mean the neighborhood knows
that like you cheated on your wife and
then like
there's it depends it could happen but
generally speaking like
it's between a man and wife right not
the public it's not something that you
have to explain to your kids until maybe
you're older and they start asking
questions about
like you know why things didn't work out
or yeah what not
yeah and then like the kids hate the
person who cheated it's like so toxic
yeah so maybe it's better well kevin and
his wife did stay together
so or maybe it's better that they don't
know or that it's just like a part of
their
reality and it's not something that they
learn later on in life and they're
really disappointed
like they just have to know things as
they happen
yeah i mean i'm not a parent but i have
no idea like what the right way to
handle this is because it's really
awkward and like it could be cause a lot
of problems like resentment
yeah but you would rather your child
find out from you
than like from google of course or from
the kids at school
yeah so i mean the kids at school are
constantly gossiping oh my god those
campers even with their masks they don't
they can't stop
[Laughter]
anyways so red table talk once again
this was a father's day special very
sweet
um happy for people who have fathers
happy father's day oh my god yesterday
on instagram was brutal
like no like not like not even an
emotional way for me but just like
no offense annoying yeah like i guess
people our age like are taking photos of
old photos like from their basement it's
just like blurry no it's just like
it was not enjoyable to be on instagram
yesterday
yeah maybe partially because i'm
resentful but maybe not
maybe not i don't know things are just
constantly getting out of hand
constantly
are you ready for our fifth and final
story that's gonna lead into our tv
recap
it's the final story
[Music]
i don't really mean to be rude but like
i felt like you started a little off
pitch
no offense i'm in multi-platinum
grammy-winning recording artist and what
have you done i
think you were off-page maybe if you had
a business that you were passionate
about
you would understand but you don't i'll
tell you what i did i hit the pitch
okay let's try it again
do it no but you you let us in come in
you started the song i joined in i just
felt like the pitch in which you started
was like a little off
so you just don't understand like
artistic creative liberty i understand
that's all you have to say
our fifth and final story khloe
kardashian reveals exactly what plastic
surgery she's had in the keeping up with
the kardashians reunion
obviously chloe's transformation was a
big topic of conversation and she shares
that
actually what she did have done is she
had her nose done and no one's ever
asked her
and said they talk about her but they
don't ask her straight up she also said
she's had filler but not a lot of botox
she doesn't react well to it which we
know kim
didn't react well to it either um okay
if okay
i maybe you didn't react well to like
botox tm
but you ladies you ladies have some
stuff in your face what is it yeah i
don't think she revealed
all the plastic surgery that she had
done but i don't think they've
ever she's right like nobody ever like
asks me what i've done
i know but it's also inappropriate to
ask it's rude it's nobody's business but
i'm glad that she shared because like
i do feel like and for me this wasn't a
lingering question but for the whole
world it clearly is like chloe's face
what'd she do
and so i'm glad that she put a lot of
these rumors to bed finally
um and stood up for herself because
everyone can really go and [ __ ] off
but i don't know and also like
same with kim like we know that she had
the botox once and she didn't like it
but like your face doesn't move so no
what you doing
so let's talk about the ass are we still
supposed to believe it's real remember
like
like season two they got like an x-ray
she's like look it's real okay
that was like eight asses ago yeah are
we are we just supposed to be living
under the guys that we all like
she does she think that we think it's
real i have no idea
well anyways i didn't even mean to bring
the story up to be negative because i
actually have overwhelmingly positive
thoughts you know even um
but that's just one thing that always
bothered me like there's stuff that's on
even like kendall
and it must bother kylie because she
gets so much [ __ ] yeah
for having her lips done and kendall and
kylie's lips are the same size no
they're not the same size but kendall
i would say maybe more than anyone looks
most different than her younger self
she looks very very different she has
she has fillers she definitely got her
nose done
she has lip injections cheek filler so
like
no you're right like kylie is like kind
of like the joan rivers of our
generation like
con like the face of plastic surgery to
the point where it's almost a joke when
like
kendall just like got just as much done
like maybe went to a better doctor
yeah or like she did it after kylie
already took all the brunt for it yeah
people just like never picked up on it
it's just it's not it's not fair no
you're right there should be equal blame
for everyone i think the only person
who's blame free would be courtney she's
or i mean yeah she looks the same but
how did she how do you stay looking the
same she looks the same
but she looks older than everyone else
not in a bad way but she like she
pretty much is the only one i think who
like attempts to age somewhat gracefully
well naturally naturally they all age
amazingly
oh yes sorry but like lean into it
almost yeah because kim looks better now
than when she was 22.
yeah yeah it makes no [ __ ] sense it
makes no sense and i just like i'm not
judging at all i want to know the
secrets like could you share with us
yeah it's honestly just like a little
rude it's a little rude that's all i'm
saying all right so let's dive into the
tv recap where we're gonna recap the
final episode of keeping up with the
kardashians
ever which is brought to you by babble
this summer get the most out of your
travels abroad by learning the language
of your destination with babel
the number one selling language learning
app from ordering in restaurants to
asking for directions to gaining a
deeper understanding of the culture
babel makes the whole process of
learning a new language addictively fun
and easy
with bite-sized lessons you can actually
use in the real world
babble is a can't miss travel essential
it's true if you're going to be
traveling somewhere
for your own safety it's so good to like
learn kind of like the bare minimum of
the language and it's just like fun and
it makes your trip like more meaningful
yeah babel's 15-minute lessons make it
the perfect way to learn a new language
on the go
unlike the infamous language classes you
took in high school babel designs their
courses with practical real world
conversations in mind
things you'll get to use in everyday
life other language learning apps
use ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be affected
because with babble you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian and german
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent
there are many ways to to learn with
babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts
games videos stories and even live
classes right now when you purchase
three month
babel subscriptions you'll get an
additional three months for free
so that's six months for the price of
three just go to babel.com and use the
promo code
tmt that's b-a-b-b-e-l dot com
code tmt for an extra three months free
love it all right final episode i
actually happen to have thought that
like part one was a little bit better
probably because they focused on kim
moore and i love chloe
but i'm just kind of tired of some of
these narratives like i really don't
need her to explain like why she wants
to change her face like it's a free
country do whatever you want
i really also don't need to hear her
explain like her choice to get back with
tristan because i have china them in my
mind
and honestly it's a free country do
whatever you want some of it was
interesting like the parts
about jordan and i did feel like it kind
of sucks for chloe that she has to be
like the broad representative for some
reason like she's a spokesperson
but some of it i just like i just didn't
i don't need an explanation on
okay here were the things that i thought
were interesting and worth even bringing
up the conversation
first the fact that chloe was like so
secure with herself before the show
started and like it was the world that
turned her insecure
someone who's so insecure and like
that's just like so sad
you can see how it all plays out and
like when she talks about how she where
i think was chris was saying she was so
secure and then she was insecure and
then she became
secure again i feel like with like
revenge body and like natural error she
was feeling so good and then like
everyone just turned on her and now it's
clear that like she it chips away at her
it really chips away at her so i thought
that that was really
interesting and sad and like how she
used to be treated so differently from
like courtney and kim on photo shoots
like
that was really heartbreaking like she
would literally get sent two outfits and
everyone got like racks and racks of
clothing
and she it's not like she was literally
like she's only lost like she was just
tall yeah and she was like what from
where she is now like maybe 10 or 20
like it wasn't that
crazy no it's not that crazy and when
she was like no it's not something that
i felt like it was just a fact
i'm not this isn't a perception like
it's just truth yeah and like
courtney and kim didn't have anything to
do with a few yeah
also i thought it was really interesting
when she was like rob feels so
horribly about what what he did pretty
much
yes oh my god that we're not gonna make
him feel any worse so it's clear they've
just like forgiven him and moved on but
just the fact that like it was
acknowledged that like
he did all he had to describe in spite
and was like with
china out of spite i thought that was
really interesting and
it makes sense how they're just like
totally moved on from it because like
why are you going to make someone feel
even more sensible no 100
like i thought it was actually crazy
that they acknowledged that
rob first of all did the satisfied and
now rob even knows it and he already
feels enough bad enough about it they're
not going to rub it in i thought that
was really interesting too like yeah
an insight into something we'd like know
nothing about because they were so hot
and heavy and like it was crazy and
kylie and her took that picture upstairs
and then there was like silence and now
china's like suing them like it's a
crazy
crazy thing and he clearly feels badly
about it i thought that was crazy
yes also scott's answer to the question
about underage girls
sucked doesn't solve anything for me can
we'll still not be talking about him
and his girlfriends no and scott was
giving me i put the emphasis on girl
scott was giving me such weird like
depressed energy like he was like
whispering and he was just like
not excited to be there and was really
giving me absolutely nothing
i don't think he's in a great place me
neither i think that he's been like
living in miami
with his girlfriend and i imagine
they're like doing miami stuff which is
like clubbing and partying i'm sure that
he's
kind of not i don't think he was ever
completely sober
no and then he like disappeared with the
shot did you see that like he was
literally there till the very end
and then he was like and he was like
let's take a shot ever and i was like i
wonder if
scott's going to take a shot of eight
one eight and then he disappeared from
the screen
oh interesting it was very weird but he
was never a sober person he was just
like
more measured back yeah exactly but i
think he was probably doing other things
also besides drinking that he has
completely stopped i just imagine his
lifestyle now is more similar to
the one he had you know when he was
getting in trouble versus the one he had
with sophia which i when i was thinking
about i was getting ready this morning i
was just like thinking about the
versions of scott and i think
scott was at his best when he was with
sophia yeah and by the way in the last
couple episodes like
of kardashians when we were talking
about scott and and courtney and she was
like there are things he didn't do that
i wanted him to do
i think pretty much like what i gathered
from last night is that it was all about
the sobriety yeah
and that he wasn't fully sober in order
for her to like actually
consider it he would have to be and he's
not yeah and so i do need like
like his response about the under
the not underneath yes super young girls
like that they find me
it was so terrible and
i no yeah i actually thought one of my
biggest takeaways from the episode was
kendall is so articulate and like really
kind of
has strong opinions when like she just
seems kind of like passe on the show
like doesn't care about anything just
like goes with the flow when she
actually like came out like pretty
strong on a few things and i thought
that her take
on the whole kardashian curse thing like
she's 100 right like it's so offensive
like
all these men can't get their life right
and it's our fault like how stupid is
that
these are grown [ __ ] men yeah and
somehow like them becoming bad at
basketball or them getting in trouble
like
has anything to do with us it's just
offensive like yeah you and chloe was
like you wouldn't say it if it was like
a family of men
yeah and all the girls who come in out
of their life get in trouble yeah
and then andy was really going for it
like asking like
because there's this huge conception
about kendall like you
cut your way to the top being the number
one paid supermodel you didn't have to
pay your dues
it was your platform it was your family
and she was like i'm actually really
bothered by that because
it's undeniable that like she had an
advantage but
i think that she did the best that she
could with that in terms of like trying
to separate herself from it i remember
she didn't want any of her family going
to the victoria's secret fashion show
so like it's undeniable but i think that
she didn't wasn't annoying about it and
she tried
to really make it on her own the best
that she can yeah also she definitely
had an advantage because she like she
had a platform and she had followers and
like in this day and age that's really
what brands are interested in but i
think like for a little
small period of time like that the
kardashian thing was kind of a
disadvantage because she was like
kind of cool considered trashy and like
commercial very commercial i don't think
anyone ever thought she would do high
fashion like okay if she wants to model
for
cassie's sure yeah but you know for
lunch
her to be doing like these crazy
campaigns i don't think anybody ever saw
that so i think she did work really hard
to
overcome some of the negative
associations about her platform too yeah
i mean still i'm sure there are like
there are things that other people had
to do that she didn't do but
there are also things that she had to
like you know work against that other
people don't have to work again yeah so
i
i thought her answer was very good and
smart and i was really surprised like
andy went there i was also really
surprised and he went with the maternity
stuff
and it's actually crazy how unbothered
chloe is like she's like of all the
things people throw on me i've been
hearing that one for so long i'm just
like
conditioned to it um and i'm not gonna
lie like i've been a fan of
the girls for a while like it's crossed
my mind yeah so i i do feel like it was
somewhat put to bed
oh for sure i feel like it's been put to
bed and i think the fact that chloe
doesn't even care about it shows just
how
untrue it is like right when someone
says something about you that's just
like completely
like insane conspiracy like you're like
oh okay yeah i
it doesn't represent my feelings but
when it's something like that you know
is and that's what kendall was saying
like it's so frustrating and why she
enjoyed the reunion so much it's like
so much is constantly being said and of
course you have to let a lot of it go
but some of it just like [ __ ] gets
you and you want to respond but you
can't respond to every stupid ass rumor
in the daily mail and cannibal was like
it was nice to just sit here and like
say what we wanted
to tear some stuff up also their
mentality is they don't want to talk
about stuff because
they give gives air too it gives it a
platform then all of a sudden even more
people who hadn't heard of it are
hearing about it so i think that's
usually how they go about things and
until you know something's everywhere
then they'll speak on it
so to just put out these little fires it
was really enjoyable
kylie was so quiet except when she
started hysterically laughing during
like a really awkward conversation
between
scott and courtney and have never
related to her more in that moment like
it actually was like palpably awkward
and i can imagine sitting between them
no and it like was so fun and light and
and she was like sitting back with him
and she was laughing i thought that was
god like a dark cloud i'm telling you
there was like something off about him
he was like whispering and he was like
monotone
and the hair like he's not his best guy
no i don't think amelia is like great
for him
no i don't think so either and like it
must be tough to like
what i what we perceive for him to be is
like in a bad place and like seeing
courtney like being maybe one of the
best places she's ever been in courtney
is in such an amazing place
like just her sitting there unboxing
both books given like um
it was it's it's really nice to see it's
i feel like it's like
it's like an age thing like with time
like you eventually just get to a place
where you just like stop caring about
every little thing and i think
chloe's younger than them so like she's
still like bothered and caught up by so
many things that like people think about
her and courtney has just like
completely let that go and i was like
envious of this like headspace she was
in it was
so peaceful yes also when
they were going around just saying their
final thoughts and kylie was like i've
put so much into my friends and
yes and you know all this has made me
realize like i have the most amazing
friends in my family and i should you
know
hang out with you guys more and kim's
like telling you that it reminds me of
snitch
so much so so much and it used to bother
me so much i was like obsessed with
kylie but i'm like why aren't you
obsessed with your sisters like
your friends are cool yeah but like
jordan and stoss like they're never
going to be there for you and the way
that your sisters are going to be there
for you
and unfortunately she had to learn that
the hard way with jordan and i think she
still loves her friends but she's not
living with her friends anymore her
family is her family and like
it sucks that she had to learn that in
like a difficult way and like learn a
hard lesson
but i'm so glad that she's like now on
the other side yeah because she's like
of course like i love my friends but
like
what better friends are than my sisters
it's like we've been telling you
yeah no it was so refreshing i've been
waiting for that moment for a long time
no it was really nice but i also think i
think kylie likes to drink and party and
i think for a long time most of her
sisters weren't
that sort of thing but i think like even
corey joining the family has like
like they have such a great connection
and like kendall now with her tequila
company like
i think there's more partying going on
for for kylie to involve herself in yes
and
i think for so long so many of the girls
had kids that were so young like you
really can't be partying that much
when your kid is still crawling but yeah
then a kid mason's huge like go out and
party you know yeah but why didn't kylie
go to kim's birthday party
which one in the in the island that is
weird you know and she's always looking
for a party like that was the party of
the year 100 party of the month not the
party of the year
that's a good question i'd like to ask
but i think all in all andy did an
incredible job like really
i've had a lot of concerns
what's the word uh grievances something
like that right yeah
gripes with the way andy's been
operating over the last couple years i
just feel like he's so disinterested in
everything that he does like on what's
happens live he looks like he would
rather be
anywhere else and i just feel like why
he
got so successful and like why i've been
obsessed with him is like he's as
obsessed with
you know housewives as we are like and i
just feel like he lost that energy that
he had for pop culture
and i thought he really was being like
oh gee vintage andy on this
special he was so interested in what
other people had to say he was asking
thoughtful hard uncomfortable questions
and i give him five out of five stars
like it was really a spectacular show
i totally agree not even lying about the
pulitzer like agreed
why not um so tonight is the bachelor i
won't be watching because i would rather
uh do anything else scratch my nails on
a chalkboard but the counselor will be
watching and there'll be a new episode
of the snatcher tomorrow so don't worry
about that
um and i believe
that's our show yeah are you sure i
think that's our show
we actually yeah we are doing something
fun right after this oh yeah
so it's not jinxing yeah because you
know if we mention it it won't happen
so that's our tomorrow that's our show
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning tell us the monday morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need each and every
monday friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcasts and where podcasts can be
found so spotify actually stitcher
public radio i heart ready to catch box
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcast find nice morning just leave a
five star review about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing monday
we'll see you tomorrow hopefully it's a
better day
goodbye goodbye